you work or volunteer with a really
remarkable woman someone who's truly
extraordinary in the community
and her family and friends nexstar our
parent company
has begun their search for remarkable
women across the united states
kirsten joyce joining us now with how
you can nominate that special woman
and a look back at the remarkable women
of 2020 in southern nevada kirsten
brian next star's kicking this off once
again wanting to highlight these
incredible women in local communities
and that woman could also be chosen as
the next star woman of the year
out of the hundreds of applicants last
time four southern nevada women were
highlighted in early 2020
this is the story of a woman who's
dedicated her life to others
the southern nevada chapter of the
american red cross nominated diane
orgill and she was ultimately chosen as
nexstar's remarkable woman of the year
for las vegas
she inspired students for more than 20
years as an educator
she also helped create the very first
spay and neuter clinic in las vegas
volunteer humanitarian teacher
wife friend
diane has many roles no one of them
small diane currently volunteers for the
american red cross available all hours
of the day and night
helping people through some of their
most vulnerable hours you're one of a
kind
and you're one of our kind and we're so
proud of you she lives a life of service
betsy dunn one of the finalists
nominated for her life of love and
selflessness
changing the lives of countless children
in the valley during two decades
she and her husband fostered nearly 150
children and adopted
seven these kids come from nowhere
and they need to know that they are
somebody
we see a lot of need in the community
finalist marnie domoroski works for a
local christian radio station
she reached out to a friend battling
terminal cervical cancer
moved the family right next door
prepared meals took the kids shopping
used the short time they had to preserve
precious memories for the kids
she was a fighter she loved her kids she
loved being a mother
and so she didn't want to give up she
wanted every opportunity
that she had finding herself a single
mother of three young children
and finalists lawana finch had two
decades of military service
earning her the rank of command sergeant
major and non-commissioned officer of
the year
she transitioned from military medicine
to groundbreaking work at the university
of utah artificial heart research
laboratory
nominated by her children sometimes like
everyone else thinking
i could have been better i could have
done this but i think
because of my ethics my integrity
and my strictness that
that all played a big part in their
lives today
those four women inspiring examples for
what we are looking for
in the 2021 next star woman of the year
so if you got someone in mind go to
8newsnow.com
nominate someone special the nomination
window closes december 20th
that in march will feature the finalist
and in april the remarkable woman from
las vegas
could become the next star woman of the
year back to you denise